i have uh two daughters i know you have
a son who's nine
yes um we all sat
and watched the the willoughbys and
i loved it so much you're
the mom helga
yes who loves to knit probably more
focused on her knitting than her
mothering
um which seems to be a trend in some of
the roles i've played but i assure you
and everyone that i'm not like that at
home i'm a very full hands-on mom
well that was what was so interesting in
the research you're such
an involved mom you love your son so
much you make decisions about your work
you put him first your friendships are
based
a lot in the development of your child
and um yeah the willoughbys goes there
like vacation they don't hold back
they don't hold back but you know my son
actually loved the movie and i was a
little
unsure when we first watched it and um
he thought it was hilarious i think he
totally gets the heightened level that
my characters exist on
um and you could tell it's a movie that
kids are gonna like when
my son watched it like four times
through and he doesn't
do that for everything i'm in like
something she doesn't even want to come
and watch or
doesn't really care but which is
probably right
and and appropriate but my kids do the
same with me some of the things i do
they really like and some that it's not
connecting yet
it was a really nice sign that he wanted
to watch it a few days in a row over and
over again even when i wasn't
home or um in the room which is a nice
thing to hear
it's so well done it's on netflix it's
maya rudolph ricky gervais u
at you know will forte it's such an
extraordinary cast and it's
a really powerful movie
i love the message that it gives in the
end that that love comes from the family
you choose not necessarily the family
you were given
and i think that's um a beautiful
message that we could use
more than ever in in our world it feels
like a little indie of an
of an animated film really to me because
it's very different tonally
than a lot of the big animated movies
that you see but i think at the core
its message is so beautiful and i i got
to work with one of my comic heroes very
closely on this which is martin short
um he plays the father and i feel like
every
moment that we shared in that movie was
inspired by him and his comedy and his
um dariness exactly what you're talking
about his
his willing to go all the way in his
comedy with every choice and every line
i think it's extremely extremely
elevated and
all families like if they haven't
already seen it check it out it's
amazing
now you're doing a reboot of name that
tune
which is such an iconic show on since
1952
and um i love how you
had a quote saying that broadway was the
heartbeat
of new york city and that you're also
getting to
feel that in the musicality of this show
you're doing now
absolutely it was one of the reasons i
really wanted to do this at first i
thought it would just be a lot of fun
and name that tune was a show that i
watched growing up in my childhood home
and would play along with my very
musical family we'd all be yelling at
the tv trying to guess
the song in as few notes as we could
against each other
as well as playing along with the
contestants which is something you can
still do now no answers are ever shown
during our game so
it's a really fun one that you could
play along with um but yeah
i i was longing to um
be in a room with live music and a live
audience again
and to feel that buzz that i really only
get
from live experience and especially from
the broadway theater
and being new yorkers um i
i have really come to feel
what what a a part of new york we're
missing by not having the broadway
lights on right now
yeah i have i really do feel that
broadway
not only brings obviously so much
revenue to new york city but
i do feel like it's part of the
heartbeat of new york
and um it's going to be a little while
till we're
we're back singing and dancing and
hoofing our
taps on on the stages of broadway again
but
i um i just sort of can't wait and i
my heart is really at this moment going
out to the entire community that makes a
broadway show
it is such a collaboration every
broadway show that you work on
and there are hundreds of people
artisans
creators people that make the shoes the
hats
the the choreography the everything i
mean obviously i think you all know all
of this but
there are so many businesses that are
losing their studios and artists that
are really struggling right now because
the broadway community is not up and
running and they are um
part of the collaboration that makes the
broadway show well hopefully
we're gonna be back there soon and until
then you're gonna do this show
[Music]